my parents don't know what I do what
they don't know what you do that's the
best maintained kept secret but when
you're like an Asian oldest daughter
I'll like pay for all the Christmas
gifts but you don't need to know that
this is sucking money I also wouldn't
tell you even if we were cool I wouldn't
be like yo I took it up
but I think you would actually
appreciate the gifts a little bit more I
actually think parents would like that
because they'll be like the sacrifice
you did for me I kind of disagree but
yeah your parents want to be cool with
that if I was stuck for like toys and
stuff no but your mom would be like what
the hell I didn't do I did the same day
I don't get no money
there's lines to this game
you're eating booty for free everyone
does it hi Mom you're on the slap we're
all full-grown cream pies
you don't think they suspect I don't
think they could tell the levels of
depravity they could probably tell I'm
like I'm a silly little girl they could
probably so their imagination won't go
that yeah I don't think they're thinking
about like gangs and stuff